Zu den geheimnisvollsten kunden und rätseln der archäologie gehören sicherlich die berühmten boden zeichnungen der nasca kultur in der wüste von süd
bewahren sie etwa als landebahnen für außerirdische gedacht oder
Nutzte die nasca kultur sie damals als gigantischen kalender in der wissenschaft hat sich jetzt an der theorie zum sinn und zweck der etwa
mysteriösen geoglyphen verfestigt was die forschung heutzutage zu den gigantischen tierbildern denkt und ob damit tatsächlich
Das große rätsel der archäologie gelüftet ist jetzt in kriegs und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Die fläche auf denen die gigantischen tierbilder, im boden zu sehen sind umfasst schätzungen zufolge fast 500
Quadratkilometer wenn man mit dem flugzeug über die wüste perus fliegt er kennt man dort zum beispiel eine spinne einen affen oder einen kolibri
um die
1500 geoglyphen sollen dort zu finden sein man nennt sie die nasca linien
benannt sind die boden zeichnung nach der nasca kultur die von etwa 200 vor bis
650 nach christus in dieser region gelebt haben soll und obwohl das schon so lange her es gibt es noch immer reichlich
Spekulationen um die geoglyphen warum und wann genau hat die nasca
Kultur sie angelegt und wozu wurden die bilder damals genutzt dazu gibt es jetzt eine neue erklärung
und zwar vom museum rietberg in zürich bis zum frühjahr werden hier in einer ausstellung beispielsweise
drohnen bilder dieser boden zeichnungen gezeigt das museum bezieht sich unter anderem auf die forschungsergebnisse vom deutschen archäologischen
institut in zusammenarbeit mit dem peruanischen
kultusministerium und anderen partnern deren grabungen laufen seit
1997 eines der ergebnisse die nasca bilder dienten den menschen damals wohl nicht zum anschauen sondern zum
Ablaufen und zwar, im rahmen besonderer rituale dazu heißt es in der pressemitteilung
Des rietberger museums die hochebenen in der wüste zwischen den bewässerten tälern als wohnort und den bergen als sitz der götter
bilden zwischen dem leben und dem göttlichen eine zwischenebene das ist ein idealer ort für die kontaktaufnahme mit dem übernatürlichen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler vermuten also dass sich die menschen damals auf den bildern bewegt haben dass sie diese quasi
Rituell abgeschrieben sind dazu gab es wohl musik darauf deuten die funde von musikinstrumenten wie trommeln und flöten nehmen
rhythmus spielte bei diesem ritual wurde eine große rolle zudem konnten archäologie teams grell, bunte keramik
nadel linien bergen das wurde wohl bewusst bei diesen veranstaltungen
zerschlagen
forschungsteams denken dass die menschen bei diesen ritualen wohl auch psychoaktive substanzen eingenommen haben klingt alles nach
Richtig fette party doch die wurden wohl nicht einfach?
So ohne grund gefeiert es gibt klima studien die zeigen diese region gerade in dieser zeit extrem trocken wurde das legt
Nahe dass die menschen. Höhere mächte um hilfe gebeten haben könnte konkret. Um das
lebensnotwendige wasser die bilder also eine folge des damaligen
Klimawandels in dieser region man könnte sich die szenerie dann also etwa, so vorstellen, im süden perus würde es immer heißer und trockener
Die nasca sind verzweifelt und so gibt es jede menge
prozession ein priester geht voran die anderen menschen folgen ihm
Sie schreiten entlang der konturen des apfels der spinne und des kolibris dabei machen sie musik mit trommeln und panflöten viele der menschen
Befinden sich in einer art heiligem rausch sie opfern den göttern und früchte und andere symbole für wasser sie alle flehen um hilfe
Wasser wird dringend benötigt doch die forschungsergebnisse weisen auch noch auf etwas anderes hin und zwar dass ein teil dieser
gehhilfen schon vor der zeit der nasca kultur angelegt worden sind und zwar von menschen aus der gegend des
südamerikanischen paracas quasi die
vorläufer der nasca kultur doch eigentlich ein und dasselbe volk demnach ist die paracas kultur um etwa 200 vor christus
Geendet doch nach jetzigem wissenstand wurde sie dann zwei kilometer weiter entfernt
weitergeführt und zwar in form der nasca kultur wenn auch in leicht abgeänderter form diesen schluss ziehen die
Archäologen und archäologen da sie keine hinweise auf größere gruppen an neuankömmlingen in der region finden konnten die geoglyphen
machten jedoch in dieser zeit einen riesigen wandel durch
Derzeit der paracas entstanden bilder die nur wenige meter groß waren die boden zeichnung wurden mit der zeit immer größer
zudem übertrug die parkas kultur sie aus der vertikalen in die
horizontalen weiter richtung pampas dass dieser zeit also 200 vor christus stammt wohl auch
61 meter langer orca hier verschiebt sich das zentrum der kultur wohl gerade von paradiesler anders kam ab dieser zeit
Lebten die menschen die bilder auf den ebenen selbst anderen nicht mehr an der abbruchkante der pampa, zudem gingen sie immer mehr in richtung
Geometrischer form wie trapez oder linien bis zu mehreren kilometer lange ist wirklich total
Beeindruckend wie und was kulturen zu entwickeln und welche rätsel sie uns dann manchmal aufgeben wenn er kein video zu diesen themen
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht dem
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Aliens zehn gründe für ihre existenz da geht es um zehn hinweise und indizien für aliens das spielt nasca auch eine rolle aber
Das ist ja nun widerlegt dann bleibt nur noch neun aber die sind auch ziemlich spannend ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran